have you heard about this poses at
funerals dead bodies imposes at funerals
this is the new big thing but don't take
my word for it let's look at the video
the life of the party even though she's
dead friends of New Orleans socialite
Miki Easter Lane through their pal a
grand old funeral down in the bayou
not one stone was left unturned unless
she looks
like sitting in a garden scenery to
depict a backyard the 83 year olds
daughter said her mom loved the
limelight loved the attention so there
she was kind of posed with the help of
some extreme embalming yeah there she is
I mean she looks stuffed and taxidermied
and all that good stuff but if you
didn't get enough of a view of this we
got two pictures of other people that I
have been put in poses post posthumously
so the dead guy is the guy in the hoodie
with the sunglasses a little unclear to
me for a second and the people on the
right is his wife in his girlfriend one
more and then we'll come back let's look
at this next one look at this guy huh is
he having fun in death or what wondering
did he die on his motorcycle because
that's a little that's a pretty light
helmet he's wearing there I say go for
more of that kind of stuff yeah there
should be everything everything that was
the moment before you die you should be
posed in it you know the diorama of
death yeah yes I think a whole Museum of
these things yeah right that's a moment
before yes of course oh there's the guy
cleaning the good are the people [ __ ]
the guy doing the order yeah that's
something where you can do a conic ones
you know like Johnny Carson doing his
golf swing my dad of course wanted to be
thrown out of a helicopter and just left
wherever he landed you were a good set
as the jaw yeah I decided again I see
what pose what I choose really so that
was my last question what would you
choose Hey here it is okay your camera
your death pose
[Laughter]
[Applause]
question mark above your head always
always um this seems this actually seems
kind of cool to me what we don't talk
about death alright we don't we don't
sort of that the video it was a
celebration of this woman's life they
had her doing the things that she loved
yes it's a little weird I suppose but
but other cultures I mean you know you
go to you go to India and you know
people are carrying the dead-body down
to the Ganges and burning the bodies
right there I mean it's an event a
family comes it it's a celebration it's
a you know they're connected with with
it I think it's I think it's a I think
it's a step in the right direction I
really do yeah yeah yeah absolutely what
are the Irish doing that I had a wake oh
yeah they have a party it's a party we
had talked about all the funny fun stuff
the person did so they're kind of come
alive yeah all the stories and that had
drunk without sleeves on anyway and I
love the socialite I love that and she I
guessed arranged the whole thing and had
ideas and knew what she wanted and yeah
you know good Anya how soon until we do
a little animatronics with these people
- that's the the next step right all
right watch out for the freaky guy that
wanted the love doll knock it off
yeah knock it off
[Laughter]
do we need to discuss death more in this
society we've talked about a little bit
on your show and I've done your show and
I feel like it is something that we
don't have a real sort of healing
discussion well I think it underlies a
lot of what drives us in this country
are our consumerism is driven by our
fear of death you know we don't want to
have a quiet moment we don't know how to
sit still and not be putting something
either in our eyeballs or our mouth you
know and and that's that is a fear of
death that's the underlying you know
denial of that that great monster are
always around the corner the the great
unknown the biggest unknown yeah you
must give me something deep the science
is now projecting that a person can live
in the next half of this century the
wealthy should be able to get the you
know Elysium machine to keep them alive
for a hundred and fifty years exhausting
have you heard about that hundred and
fifty years
let me guess springtime sure pretty
[ __ ] sure Oh [ __ ] flower a hundred
and fifty god damn springtime American
Idol eighty nine I was ready to be
killed after American Idol
[Music]